Zach low you're on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing Zach I'm hanging in ready
to go back to this for the fourth
straight time unbelievably what does
Warriors Cavs for me exactly what does
it say this was the first time that I
feel kind of tired of it I was kind of
hoping for a little bit of a fresh City
a fresh look but what it says more than
anything else is just the greatness of
LeBron and and the margin for error that
the Warriors have after they signed KD I
mean they had they didn't really play a
great series they faced the first
opponent who really tested them and in
the end you know none of it mattered
their talent was just overwhelming and
LeBrons talent was overwhelming in the
east and now we get to see it again I
don't know how competitive it will be
but we'll see well I mean if Dahl is not
healthy enough to cover LeBron I you
know not to call him the the Dumars of
the I guess LeBron rules but if he's not
able to to be there I mean that that's
something that levels the playing field
a little bit
that said I'm wondering if the if the
Cavs have this switching defensive
ability that the Rockets had to throw
the Warriors off their offensive game
like they did in the middle part of that
Western Conference Finals what do you
think I mean they don't nobody does I
mean that's why the Rockets were such a
unique opponent and then they built
their team specifically for this series
Jeff Green is an interesting piece for
them but you know in George Hill who
sort of hasn't really played up to his
reputation for the Cavs is interesting
too but you know he's still too little
to guard KD and they still have Kevin
Love so it's not it's not an ideal
roster construction but you know it's
very hard to get the ideal roster
construction Zac low of worldwide leader
in sports espn.com joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show where does this
these playoffs leave with James Harden
in your mind Zac you know I
he's gonna win the MVP I'll have
deserved it I think it actually leaves
him in a better place I think he wore
down a little bit in in Game seven last
night but he was relentless he's the
second scariest person with the ball in
his hands in the NBA is behind LeBron
the step-back three is really made him
sort of unguardable you know to the
point where he makes it enough enough of
them anyways I and I think he I think
he earned the respect of the Warriors
and I don't know how much they feared
him right they don't fear respect him on
the level of a little brawn but I think
it by the end of this series
they were like man this dude is
relentless he just keeps on coming I
know that said as you were making your
comments our television side of things
is just showing one missed three by hand
another and it's and it's difficult to
and I said in the second before you
joined us here that there should be a
Most Valuable Player Award for the
postseason in every sport by the way not
just basketball because you know the MVP
trophy is gonna be accepted in late June
by a guy that was part and parcel of a
twenty seven in a row
missed three-point extravaganza Zach
it's kind of tough to square that circle
I mean the MVP awards the regular season
right and and LeBron is the best player
everybody knows LeBron is the best
player I think it was hard to get past
how uninspired the Cavs were in the
regular season and how much drama just
shakes up that team every year but yeah
it's interesting because you know you
want to say the Finals MVP is kind of
the most outstanding player but LeBron
didn't win it three years ago when it
was Dellavedova and a bunch of other
cast offs in him I actually voted for
LeBron a year but he didn't win it and
if you didn't win it that year I'm not
sure it's possible for anyone on the
losing team to ever win the Finals MVP
again Jerry West is the only one who's
done it so maybe there should be
something for the whole playoffs may be
here right here so where do you stand on
the LeBron MJ of it all now that LeBron
has made eight finals of his career I
mean I said last year Jeff Van Gundy and
I had old podcast about this I think it
became a conference a legitimate
conversation of peers last year when
they just blitzkrieg the entire Eastern
Conference and made the finals again
losing only one game and I think it's a
legitimate conversation now I think
they're essentially equal players and if
LeBron keeps playing like this in two
three four years I mean the only ammo
you're gonna have to say that Michael
was out ranking him is just the sheer
number of championships and if that's
the ammo if that's the argument then
that's going to be an unwinnable
argument for LeBron
but I think all the other arguments are
gonna point in his direction so it's
it's sort of you know I have the
beholder kind of thing at this point the
fact that he might go somewhere else
though in a couple of weeks how might
that changed the dynamic the fact that
Jordan had obviously two errors of his
own am surrounding his baseball for a
but with the same team LeBron going Cavs
Heat
Cavs and now another destination
potentially I said I guess this is a
two-part question for you how did that
game seven win perhaps change that
dynamic for July 1 and how what is
departing change any of the dynamic of
what you mentioned about the Jordan
conversation Zac I I mean I guess the
game seven win probably changed it at
least a little bit it proves to him that
yes even with the supporting cast in the
east for now until Boston gets healthy
in Philadelphia sort of matures I can
still get back to the finals but both of
those things may change next year with
those two teams so I'm not sure how much
it matter to everything has to matter a
little bit I think what would matter a
lot more is if they're surprisingly
competitive in this series that really
make it a series and push them hard but
if he changes teams again you know I
mean I Michael Jordan wouldn't played
baseball for two years in the middle of
his private I don't know what what is an
apple what is an orange how to
distinguish between the two it doesn't
really bother me or or paint LeBrons
legacy in any way if he's on you know
team why next year and in terms of him
potentially hooking up with somebody on
July 1 to go to a different team who's
more who's more apt to join LeBron in
just a package deal somewhere core or
join him in Cleveland
Paul George Kawhi Leonard which one do
you think is more apt to hook up with
LeBron come July 1 I mean I think you
got to start with PG only because you
know he's a free agent and so his
flexibility is much easier the Spurs
have Kawhi under contract for another
year and therefore hold more cards and
introduced a sort of third-party that
can make things a little bit more
complex so I think you have to start
with PG but yeah I mean beat the entire
offseason starts with those three guys
LeBron Paul George and kawaii can throw
Chris Paul in there too but you know
those three Domino's are going to define
what is
to be just an absolutely bonkers July
whenever it starts yeah so how do you
think the Chris Paul dynamic plays out
now that the Rockets are are sitting
home fishing or what however you want to
put it I think I think he goes back
there you know I my guess is that there
were expectations of a full five-year
max contract when they when they
acquired him you know I'm sure that
Houston feels a little bit queasy about
years four and five of that deal given
that he just suffered another postseason
injury in his 33 and and point guards
typically don't age very well but I
would suspect Houston looks at this and
says we were that close this team works
we'll have to adjust it here there
because Trevor Ariza is a free agent and
we have some other come Clint capela as
a free agent but I think they bring CP
back what the rest of the team looks
like we'll be a little bit unclear but I
think he goes back alright a couple more
minutes left with Zach Lowe espn.com
senior NBA reporter how do you see the
finals playing out how do you see it
happening you know it with dollars
injuries you should as you said throws a
little bit of a wild card in but the
talent gap is so overwhelming in Golden
State's favor once you get past
obviously the best player in the world
that it's just hard to see this
unfolding any other way but what last
year was which was 4:1 and and that Cavs
team was better than this one you know
maybe this one has some defensive
flexibility that that what that one
didn't have but you got to have
offensive firepower to keep up with the
Warriors and and the loss of Kyrie
Irving really kills them in that regard
so it's hard to see this is a long
super-competitive series but you know
LeBron makes things happen yeah man
you just gave I mean I could hear the
resignation in your voice a little bit
Zack you are you are you're you got the
fatigue you got the Warriors fatigue and
the Cavs coming coming coming to the
party through an Eastern Conference
that's not as good as the West so you
don't know how battle-tested they are
there is LeBron as the the difference
maker and they just seem a couple of a
couple of cards shine the deck it feels
like Zack ended and you know what we
will see right I mean it somehow squeeze
out game one who who the
knows what happens but it does feel like
we just saw the the hardest punch the
Warriors are gonna take in the playoffs
and you know this is why there are
people who argue for receiving the
playoffs are just seeding them 1 to 16
regardless of conference or whatever you
want to do to get that matchup in the in
the finals instead of in the semifinals
but that that hasn't happened and here
we are
you'd be sitting you Megan you would be
for that you'd you'd son um you know III
have I have I think it's to me it's more
important to get the 16 team's best the
16 best teams in the playoffs and the
seeding aspect of it I would be Phi mean
Adam silver is always said to travel and
in the unbalanced schedule are obstacles
that are not solvable right now
there's certainly some truth in that you
know you got a Portland Miami first
round series followed by another one
cross-country for the team that when
that is a problem I think there are ways
around that maybe you go back to two
three - maybe you shortened the first
round to five games I don't know I'm
just spitballing but I do like the idea
of a the 16 best teams get in like the
Nuggets this season and be you seed so
that your two best teams can't meet
until the finals Zack appreciate the
time let's chat again real soon the lo
podcast check it out on all platforms at
ESPN offers and then senior NBA write
every SPN dot-com let's chat again soon
thank you sir you got it that's Zach
Lowe here on the show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience